[Music]
let's go let's go let's go
hey guys Pete here well we saw a lot of
different endings and moved past the
Better Call Saul timeline in episode
nine it's safe to say things will never
be the same and now it's kind of hard to
imagine what these next four episodes
will look like that's not to say that
that's a bad thing it's actually pretty
exciting and if everything that came
before is any indication then we're
definitely in for a treat the only
question we can expect to get an answer
to Is what will happen to Gene takovic
that's been set up over the first five
seasons there is a payoff coming in that
timeline we know from the teasers that
Jeff will make another appearance even
though it looks like he's going to be
played by a different actor and of
course the poster for this season is
Gene putting on that loud Red Jacket the
brief teaser they aired after episode
609 is a shot of something that looks
like it belongs in the gene timeline and
I will come back to talk about that in a
second the other big question is how can
him story will end and as much as I want
to know the answer to that they really
haven't given us anything to go on the
title of episode 610 is nippy and it's
got a really simple synopsis saying a
new player enters the game because Aaron
Paul and Brian Cranston are reported to
be returning in this episode it seems
like a good guess that the new player is
Walter White the only thing that nippy
is ever meant to me is cold and I can't
think of any breaking bad or BCS
reference that it could be related to if
you look it up there are some different
definitions but none of them are common
at least not in the United States so the
last time we saw Gene he was in Omaha
during the winter and in the teaser with
Jeff you can see that there's still snow
on the ground in case you forgot what's
more interesting about the title is that
it breaks the convention of the titles
all being something in something fun and
games point and shoot and so on even
before the breakup was confirmed people
on Reddit it we're guessing that all the
X and X titles were for episodes where
Kim and Jimmy were together and the
shift to one word would Mark the
transition to Saul being alone as you've
probably seen by now the visual Clues
including his 2005 license plate tags
and the handicap tag that expires in
2008 indicate that the time Jump at the
end of 609 takes place in 2005 which is
only about a year after Kim left writer
and producer Thomas snaz who is usually
a great source for clearing things up
kinda muddied the waters on this one by
saying on Twitter that he thought were
roughly in 2007. if he's right about
that which he should be since he was
there when they wrote the story then
that means the tags would be wrong and
that wouldn't be the first mistake they
made like that so I suppose we'll have
to wait and see I had a lot of people
asking if the public masturbator client
Saul was talking about on the phone
could be a hint that he'd be meeting
with Badger because that's what he
thought his case was when they first met
but that meeting is firmly established
to be in late 2008. it seems like a lot
of these details that we heard in that
Flash Forward are just references to get
Breaking Bad fans excited about what we
might see now that Saul is back
apparently he gets a lot of public
masturbation cases the choice of jumping
to 2005 or 2007 is kind of confusing
there must be a reason they decided not
to jump right into the events of
Breaking Bad but I wouldn't say it's
instantly obvious I guess it establishes
that he's gotten his Sandpiper
settlement and has fully embraced this
strategy of throwing himself into being
Saul full time to bury the pain that
he's carrying they did a fantastic job
in that short bit of screen time to show
how he doesn't give himself a chance to
think he has a sex worker with him when
he's at home after work and every
indication is that's a regular thing
from the time he wakes up in the morning
he's got the Bluetooth on and he doesn't
stop working I guess this being in
between the two shows timelines tells us
that he's been keeping it up for a
relatively long time by 2008 when he
meets Walt and everything changes again
what's even more mysterious is Kim's
story she doesn't give Jimmy any
indication of where she plans to go and
as much as 609 was a fitting ending for
their relationship it didn't come off as
one for the character Howard and Lalo
were both killed off which is obviously
different it's a definitive end but the
crew had shirts made for their last days
and they were featured on The Insider
podcast to talk about their experience
none of that has happened with Ray
seahorn and I might be doing my own bit
of coping by reading into that but
regardless I feel like there's a good
chance that it's a sign that there's
more to tell I mean as important as Ray
seahorn is to this show it would feel
incomplete if we didn't see her again
how that plays out and how that fits in
are the biggest unanswered Better Call
Saul questions the first thing that
comes to mind is a reunion and that
brings up hope of a type of redemption
even if it doesn't cross over into being
a happy ending I don't think you could
have watched this show closely and not
wanted that to happen happen but there's
a detail in the last episode that makes
things a little more complicated in my
videos so far I've shied away from
talking about what draws Kim and Jimmy
together because ultimately the answer
to that would be it's complicated there
are a lot of reasons but because I was
really surprised to see a lot of fans
questioning whether Kim's saying that
she didn't want things to end because
she was having too much fun meant that
she never loved him I think it's a good
time to re-examine her decision what
she's saying is that their love isn't
enough to justify their being together
since people around them get hurt Peter
Gould has said on different occasions
that they thought about addiction when
they thought about these two being
together and if you compare her decision
to treatment models it looks like she's
choosing abstinence there's a not very
subtle title of the first episode being
Wine and Roses which is a nod to the
movie Days of Wine and Roses which is
about a couple on a downward spiral
because of alcoholism if she believes
that's the only thing that will work
then it gets harder to figure out how
they might be drawn back together time
away shouldn't be enough for a character
with resolve as strong as Kim wechsler I
mean she just stopped being a lawyer
because she doesn't think she was worthy
of the profession her changing her mind
on this major decision she made on her
own terms wouldn't fit so that's all to
say that we'll have to see at least some
of Kim's life away from Jimmy to
understand how she's moved on and who
she's become and that brings us back
around to the timeline questions and I
guess since we don't know where she'll
go the location questions as well a lot
can happen in four full episodes of TV
think about what happened in the last
three in a very compressed amount of
time the show is currently untethered
from the original linear structure it
followed through Jimmy's transformation
and could do just about whatever it
wants from here as I mentioned in the
beginning this short black and white
teaser we got is a shot of a department
store or in a mall like the one gene
Works in what's happening in the
voiceover is not absolutely clear to me
it sounds like Gene has gotten on the PA
and is trying to cause a commotion by
telling Shoppers to take things for free
without context I'm not sure what else
to say about it I've been expecting
since he told Ed on the phone that he'll
take care of the problem himself that
he'll go after Jeff but how this might
fit in with that remains to be seen
there are still other teasers from the
mid-season break that we haven't seen
yet as well we haven't heard the a happy
ending line yet we haven't found out
where Kim reading the oath comes into
play and then there's the conversation
where it sounds like he's telling
someone he just paid off to take it and
just go away never come back the last
teaser from 608 did play right into the
next episode we saw Saul in his mansion
and the voiceover was from the last
thing he said at the end of the episode
that makes me think there's a good
chance we'll see Gene in this episode
but it's confusing because I wouldn't
expect to spend the whole episode there
primarily because for Walton Jesse to
show up together we need to be in or
around the Breaking Bad timeline it's
possible that they might jump around we
could see a Flash Forward at the
beginning of the episode we could see
them jump into the gene timeline at the
end of the episode like the last one and
then what I've been thinking about more
is that I'm hoping to see some Gene
scene equivalents in Kim's life after
Albuquerque so it could take on a whole
different direction and feel from what
we watched so far there were no promo
pictures at all this week to give any
additional Clues and I think this is a
pretty good place to be I'm ready to be
surprised and I'm ready to be blown away
with whatever they came up with in a
prequel Series where everything had to
line up to the original to make sense
we're truly in Uncharted Territory it's
an exciting time to be a fan and I'm so
excited I'm going to be doing a preview
stream on Saturday to talk about it with
some friends I do like the addiction
analogy when it comes to Kim's decision
and we'll be talking about that some
more in the Stream if you think about
their progression how would they
recapture the magic from scams like what
they started out with after what they
pulled off with Howard before things
went wrong what they were able to do
there was impressive and so where would
that end you'd just be chasing that high
you could never get and she's right a
lot more people could get her hurt so
let me know in the comments what you
think will happen do you think Carol
Burnett will show up in the Breaking Bad
timeline or the gene timeline and
overall how are you hoping the series
will end please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon